good morning hick it's Tuesday I'm a
little bit overwhelmed with anxiety at
the moment here's a video about how to
make hot sauce if you want your hot
sauce to cost about $65 per bottle so
first you're going to want to buy this
portable planter thing and put it
somewhere in your house for me the guest
bathtub then through the magic of Water
and Light turn some seeds into pepper
plants you want these pepper plants to
be weird by the way like anybody these
days can get ghost peppers I'm talking
about weird early 20th century varietals
of Habaneros and lipstick peppers and
paper lanterns right so you these seeds
in a bathtub which is a totally normal
thing to do and around April they're
ready to plant in the garden now this
process will be timec consuming and
annoying but don't worry the process of
weeding and watering over the next four
months will be much more timec consuming
and annoying but you're not doing this
to make yourself happy really you're
doing it to kind of keep yourself sane
like it's just good news for you to have
to touch plants and take care of
something right So eventually you'll
have a bunch of beautiful peppers and
you'll begin to harvest them in their
literal thousands because you went just
a a little over the top this year and
ended up with a lot of peppers now once
you got the peppers harvested it's time
to finally start to make the hot sauce
which is inexplicably going to occur in
vertical video first you got to cut the
stems off the peppers and then toss them
into a blender and you really want to
crush their little pepper soles until
they're quasi liquefied now we're making
a pepper Mash hot sauce so once the
peppers are Blended you add the
appropriate amount of salt around a
tablespoon for every 3 lbs of peppers
but don't worry if you get this wrong
it's not like the entire process will be
ruined or anything just kidding it will
anyway then you pour your Mash into a
fermentation jar and close up the jar
and write what the heck you just made in
Sharpie because you will forget like
this one is called mostly Scotch bonnet
on account of how it's mostly Scotch
bonnet peppers and then every day as
you're getting the kids ready for school
you burp the jars which just means
opening them up a tiny bit so the gas
can come out I don't know what kind of
gas I don't know how fermentation works
and then after about 3 weeks of
fermentation it's time to open the jars
which is what we in the pepper business
call the big money no whammies moment
because if you mess something up there
will be a bunch of mold on the jar and
in the pepper mash and all of your work
up to now will have literally been for
nothing and then you'll stare into the
middle distance for a while and wonder
why you put yourself through this every
year when you don't even like hot sauce
this much although for the record
homemade hot sauce is Miles better than
the store stuff but look lucky you there
is no mold Hallelujah now it's time to
actually make some hot sauce cut up four
cloves of garlic out 1/4 cup of white
wine vinegar if you're an artist like me
you might have the vinegar already be
spicy because it's pepper vinegar your
mom made with some of your 10,000 excess
Peppers now mush that all together mush
go to the highest mush setting look at
that my God it's beautiful now you taste
test with your finger because you're
classy and it is good it's really good
wow is it good now you take your funnel
and bottle that hot sauce you can't sell
this because it wasn't made in a
commercial kitchen and also because the
only way to make it profitable would be
to charge like $80 a bottle so instead
you'll give it out to family and friends
for the holidays now you have hot sauce
and you feel a little less anxious
because it's good to have hobbies in
this world especially if it's a hobby
you get to share with your mom Hank I'll
see you on Friday and it's pepper uh
well it's actually just pepper and
vinegar that tell you that it's all
voice over oh oh yeah so I'd like for
you to touch it and make a
face know